i
vont et qui font à peu près
n'importe quoi, des feux un peu
partout parce qu'il y a un
élément de respect qu'on ne voit
plus. Monsieur François Arteau,
un citoyen, nous a écrit, je
suis allée le rencontrer et on a
posé des questions.
- Bonjour, M. Arteau.
- Bonjour, M. Roy.
Merci de nous avoir écrit.
- Oui.
- On est dans votre jardin.
(rire)
Au parc Angrignon, Sud-Ouest
de Montréal, et ça vous rend
triste de voir qu'on l'a laissé
aller complètement.
FRANÇOIS ARTEAU, président,
Les amis du parc Angrignon
- Oui. Disons que pour beaucoup
de monde dans le quartier
et les arrondissements
environnants, le parc Angrignon,
depuis des années, il y a pas
eu d'investissements importants.
Tous les bâtiments sont fermés
depuis... au moins plus que
10 ans... au moins une dizaine
d'années. Donc, comme les
quartiers... l'ancier Quartiers
d'hiver qu'on a ici à côté.
- C'est une belle image.
Ça montre la décrépitude
du parc. Puis ça, Arteau,
ça fait combien d'années
que des citoyens sonnent
la cloche en disant :
"On peut pas laisser aller
un joyau comme ça"?
- Si on regarde l'histoire,
où il y a eu beaucoup de
promesses de projets en 2013-
2015, les règlements d'emprunt
étaient faits et tout ça,
les projets étaient comme
à être réalisés, et jamais rien
ne s'est réalisé. Donc, on veut
pas que cette même situation-là
se reproduise.
- Parce que c'est magnifique,
ça reste magnifique, parce qu'il
y a des arbres, il y a la...
Mais il faut lui donner de
l'amour. Il faut s'en occuper.
- C'est ça, parce qu'il est
considéré comme un des grands
parcs, mais ce qu'il a de
particularité : il est classé
comme parc urbain comme le parc
La Fontaine, mais il y a
une majorité de sa section
qui est considérée zone à
protéger, comme un parc nature.
Donc, il a comme double
vocation autant de parc urbain
que de milieu naturel. Il a
de la valeur quand même assez
exceptionnelle. C'est le seul
grand parc de tout le Sud-Ouest
de l'île de Montréal. Puis,
comme grandeur, si on le compare
au parc La Fontaine, c'est
presque trois fois la superficie
du parc La Fontaine.
- Puis là, si vous voulez aller
aux toilettes, ici, avec votre
famille, il y a juste ça?
- C'est ça.
- Il n'y a plus aucun bâtiment
qui est ouvert.
- Non.
- Donc, il s'agit pas de...
réinventer la roue, mais vous
dites : "Il faut s'occuper
de nos affaires".
- C'est ça, il faut s'assurer
de préserver cette qualité-là
de parc, parce qu'à l'intérieur
du parc, il y a aussi des
plantes qui sont même classées
vulnérables, comme le trille
blanc, qu'on retrouve ici en
très grand nombre, qui commence
à être de plus en plus rare
dans les parcs de Montréal.
On a en à profusion, mais
le fait que les gens se
promènent partout dans le boisé,
ils font ce qu'on appelle
des sentiers illicites,
ils piétinent partout, ça met en
péril à long terme cette plante-
là aussi, donc ça fait partie
de... de ce qu'on veut qui soit
préservé pour garder ça
pour les générations futures.
- Merci beaucoup, M. Arteau.
Grâce à vous, on est mieux
informés, puis on va aller
poser la question au maire
de l'arrondissement, M. Dorais :
qu'est-ce qu'il attend pour
mettre un peu d'investissements
ici? Merci.
- Merci beaucoup.
♪ ♪ ♪
- M. Dorais, bonjour.
- Bien le bonjour!
- Quel lieu merveilleux
pour se voir.
- C'est... c'est vraiment
merveilleux et fantastique.
- On est chez vous.
- On est chez nous.
- Vous êtes responsable de...
BENOIT DORAIS, maire, arrond.
du Sud-Ouest, Projet Montréal
- On est chez nous, non
seulement parce que je suis
maire, mais parce que ça fait
46 ans que j'habite
l'arrondissement du Sud-Ouest,
alors on est vraiment chez nous.
- Bon. Là, M. Arteau,
le citoyen, est inquiet,
il y en a plusieurs qui sont
inquiets. On a laissé ce parc-là
à l'abandon. Pourquoi, d'abord?
- Bien, tout d'abord, c'est
vrai. Pendant des décennies,
le parc Angrignon a été laissé
à l'abandon par plusieurs
administrations successives.
Et ce qu'il fallait, c'était
de travailler, dès le début
du mandat, avec les services
centraux. Et on leur a dit :
"Il faut réinvestir dans le parc
Angrignon".
- Ça fait quand même quatre ans.
Pourquoi il y a rien qui a été
fait? Parlons du passé,
on va parler de l'avenir proche,
mais pourquoi il y a rien
qui a été fait? Ça débloquait
pas pourquoi? Parce que c'était
trop ambitieux, le plan?
Pourquoi ça débloquait pas?
- Bien, premièrement, on peut
pas tout faire dès le début
du mandat, puis il y a
un certain nombre d'études
qui devaient être faites.
Puis là, on parle pas des études
qui servent à toutes sortes
d'affaires; il nous fallait
des vraies stratégies pour se
dire que la forêt laurentienne,
ici, on doit vraiment lui
redonner ses droits. Ce qu'on
voulait faire, c'était de se
dire : "Considérant que les gens
nous demandent de réorienter
la vocation du parc Angrignon".
Pendant longtemps, on dirait
que c'était l'extension
de la Ronde. Les gens venaient
ici, ils faisaient le party,
ils faisaient toutes sortes
d'affaires. On veut pas ça.
Le parc a besoin d'être
chouchouté morceau par morceau
pour faire changer
les mentalités.
Et les investissements
s'en viennent rapidement.
- Vous dites aux gens,
en conclusion, du Sud-Ouest
et d'ailleurs, qu'Angrignon va
se réformer, va se morderniser
en termes d'accès aux toilettes,
en termes de sentiers
d'ici quoi, deux, trois ans,
vous dites? C'est ce que
je comprends.
- Environ deux, trois ans,
parce que déjà, on a revu
les panneaux de signalisation.
Déjà, on a planté des arbres.
Il y a 3580 arbres qui ont été
faits. Pour la propreté,
on a mis 62 nouvelles poubelles.
- Une petite vite : Quartiers
d'hiver, vous faites quoi avec
ça? Est-ce que vous démolissez
ça?
- Ah, non! Ça, c'est
patrimonial. Ça, c'est
patrimonial.
- Donc, il va arriver quoi?
- C'est vraiment le pôle
d'accueil du parc Angrignon.
Ce qu'on veut, c'est vraiment...
- Vous allez le rénover?
- Oui, tout à fait. Tout à fait.
- Avec un chalet, puis...
- On rénove ça ici...
- Aller prendre un petit café...
T'sais, des choses qui vont
de soi!
- Oui! Mais ça, on est pas
rendus à ce niveau de détails-
là. Moi, je veux surtout
préserver le bâtiment
patrimonial qui est là,
en faire effectivement un chalet
d'accueil. Puis, les gens nous
diront comment ils veulent,
justement, l'opérer. Nous,
ce qu'on voudrait, c'est une
entreprise d'économie sociale.
Ça, ça ressemble au Sud-Ouest.
C'est ça qu'on veut pour
le Quartiers d'hiver.
- Très bien. M. Dorais,
on va suivre ça avec attention.
Merci.
- Suivez-nous, parce que ça va
être là.
(rires